[Music]
so Hank Willie is four months old today
which means that while he's still
technically a very tiny little puppy
he's also acquired some serious skills
like for instance he was a total expert
at the skill of down down stay yes good
I'll be good boy and he totally knows
how to sit and sit yes good huh he's
also quite good at what our obedient
school calls retrieve go fetch go get
yes now bring it back bring it back okay
sort of he doesn't really retreive you
just sort of trees I don't want to take
anything away from Willie skill set I
mean for someone who has a brain the
size of a baby fist I think he's kind of
a genius but while all of those skills
are useful there's one that we would
really really like Willie to master I am
of course referring to the thing where
he turns his head to the side like he's
at night at the Roxbury so when we first
got Willie here's what we figured out
Willie does the thing where he turns his
head to the side whenever he hears a
series of sounds that he's never heard
before in his life
so like for the first month we were on
easy street because he'd never heard any
sounds and we could just do anything and
he would do the head turn thing and we
would just be like oh so cute but then
it started to get a little harder I
found myself reaching into the depths of
my vocal chords looking for new sounds
they could make and now Hank it has come
to this please observe the Yeti and I
trying to get Willie to do the head turn
thing for the camera go do a little
dance come on I got ya
Oh your clothes it's also places he's
betting days oh do the head thing
no that was a head thing but that wasn't
the one I was thinking of I mean I can't
even think of another noise what what
kind of like what this is chic shrieking
oh good idea
oh yeah okay so as far as we can tell it
has to be a human voice making sounds
that Willie's never hurts before clearly
we are out of such sound so if anyone
wants to make a video response making a
sound that they think Willie has never
heard before we would certainly
appreciate it
Hank I will do a real video soon and
I'll see you later this week